so today I want to talk about why
entrepreneurs must learn how to run
first before they can walk I'm Patrick
beta via host of IBM weekly and the
court I referenced earlier is actually
quote from Tony Stark
from the movie Iron Man where he says
sometimes we must learn how to run first
before we can walk and I think that
quote has so much to do with startup
entrepreneurs here's why you see when
you have when you're a startup
entrepreneur you don't have the luxury
of pondering about your next move and
taking two weeks to say well maybe maybe
not
you don't have that kind of luxury as a
startup entrepreneur because every day
you're a day away from being out of
business as a start-up entrepreneur you
don't have the luxury of the big
businesses where they got a sitter on
and they can spend six months to think
about their next move now you also have
the benefit because you're nimble and
you can make the move faster while they
have to go through a lot of different
boards and organizations and approvals
and you know all this sign up said that
you don't need to do that you can just
simply make your next move but as a
start-up entrepreneur I see sometimes
amateur entrepreneurs they'll sit there
and they say but but the bigger company
has this but we're Walmart but Sears has
been around for 80 years and we don't
but we're Apple and we'll just new but
iBM has so much more resources and we're
big you don't have time to do that you
just got to make your next move if you
got a military you don't have a lot of
fancy weaponry and you don't have a lot
of fancy jets like maybe an f-22 Raptor
or an f-18 if you don't have those
things you gotta use the weapons you got
and it's kind of like a game where the
better you do the more battles you win
the better weapons you get the stronger
weapons you get the stronger tools you
get and eventually you can call timeouts
and say let's think about this next move
let's think about that next move let's
put a team to come up with the best
strategy for this this but it seems to
come out with the best strategy for this
but you have a long ways to go to get
there where you can stop and walk
instead of running so your best friend
as a start-up entrepreneur is being as
urgent as you can be so my message of
the week and please be sure to subscribe
to this channel and comment on the
bottom
ready you know Tony Stark from I'm
Patrick may give your host a value
taming weekly in the quote I talked
about how you I laugh and asked my
goodness you guys seriously this is it
we did my voices gots delicious I'm the
quote the quote the quote the quote I
talked about